[Music]  alas another clue to Jack's death on  this is us now if you haven't watched  look away it's my fault I'm the reason  that he's dead  Kate maybe the reason he died it started  when teenager Kate saw the cracks of her  dad's relationship with mom Rebecca are  you and Mom all right stop it we're fine  you don't seem fine  look it's marriage okay just just stuff  that's fine well Jack eventually does  decide to take the two-hour drive to  Ohio slightly buzzed I wanted you to  know that you were right I'm gonna fix  things with your mom I love you Katie go  it's during Williams fun a role nope not  even a smile for fun that Kate is  reminded of her own dad's death her  bombshell opens more clues about how it  happened but as my little Ventimiglia  told ET you'll never see it coming  it could be next episode it could be the  second to last episode it could be a ye  aways away  [Music]